[Música]
se agudiza la atención entre occidente y
rusia el presidente de estados unidos
joe biden advirtió sobre las sanciones
directas contra su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin si invade ucrania a su
vez el mandatario francés emmanuel
mcconnell conversará con putin el
viernes para poder elegir clarifique sus
intenciones
hubo un uso excesivo de la fuerza por
parte del estado chileno en las
protestas de 2019 así lo confirma la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos en su más reciente informe en el
que indica que el actuar de las
autoridades afectó el derecho a la
protesta pacífica ampliamos desde
santiago
pese a la condena internacional tras el
golpe de estado en burkina faso más de
1000 jóvenes salieron a las calles de
varias ciudades para mostrar su apoyo a
los militares a su vez la cedeao aseguró
que el depuesto presidente rock kaboré
se vio obligado a renunciar bajo
amenazas
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos el conflicto entre rusia y
occidente se recrudece el presidente de
eeuu joe biden
no descarto la posibilidad de imponer
sanciones directas contra su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin si se concreta la
invasión a territorio ucraniano ante un
eventual fracaso de la vía diplomática
la otan ya ha anunciado que reforzará su
pie de fuerza en europa del este
mientras que rusia amplificó su
despliegue militar en belarús país que
también recibió advertencias de
washington informa judis muñoz
es un paso poco común imponer sanciones
directamente al presidente de otra
nación es un camino que por lo general
eeuu busca evitar pero ahora joe biden
no descarta castigar directamente a
vladimir putin si es que invade ucrania
personalmente sancionándolos invade
ucrania si lo haría tendría que
no tenemos intención de poner fuerzas
estado evidencia sobre la otan en
ucrania pero como he dicho habrá serias
consecuencias económicas y el avanza
sin embargo la ayuda militar sigue
llegando a ucrania y analistas
estadounidenses advierten de la gravedad
del conflicto
y creo que estamos ante el conflicto
potencialmente más significativo desde
la segunda guerra mundial rusia habría
desplegado unos 100.000 soldados en la
frontera con ucrania
emanuel macrón presidente de francia
llamará a putin el viernes para pedirle
que clarifique sus intenciones y envió
una advertencia sin duda bajo en
agresión si hay un ataque habrá
respuesta y el costo será muy alto el
lucus silva
mientras tanto alexander lukashenko
presidente de lanús confirmó acciones
conjuntas con rusia
me vio obligado a hacerlo porque la
situación en la frontera con ucrania no
es mejor que en la frontera con polonia
y antes de la búsqueda eeuu también ha
advertido a belarús de consecuencias se
ayuda a rusia en una eventual invasión
desde moscú acusan a washington de
aumentar tensiones al poner en alerta a
8 mil 500 soldados para ser desplegados
en europa si fuese necesario mientras
eeuu prepara sus socios la respuesta a
las garantías de seguridad exigidas por
moscú como frenar la expansión de la
otan a ucrania o el cese de cooperación
militar con las ex repúblicas soviéticas
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
anunció que aspirará a un decimonoveno
término en el congreso al presentarse a
la reelección en los comicios de
noviembre la líder demócrata de 81 años
aseguró que su decisión se debe a que
hay una necesidad crucial de defender la
democracia estadounidense
pelosi pone así fin a las especulaciones
sobre su retiro aunque no confirmó que
aspiraría a mantener el rol del líder de
la bancada demócrata en la cámara baja
estos momentos en que las estrechas
mayorías oficialistas podrían verse
amenazadas en las elecciones de este
2022 pero si llegó al congreso en
1987 marcó la historia al convertirse en
la primera mujer portavoz de la cámara
en 2007 provech la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
publicó un informe sobre lo ocurrido
durante las protestas en chile de 2019
el reporte ratifica que hubo un uso
excesivo de la fuerza pública y eso
afectó el derecho a la protesta pacífica
también evidenció hostigamientos de
parte de agentes del estado de diversos
sectores de la sociedad entre ellos la
prensa el texto califica como paso
histórico hacia la reconciliación a la
convención constitucional instalada con
el fin de redactar una nueva carta magna
desde santiago el periodista de france
24 leonardo honores tiene los detalles
hace dos años una delegación de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos él visitó chile para conocer en
terreno cuál es la situación de los
derechos humanos específicamente en el
país luego del estallido social sus
conclusiones recogidas en 125 páginas
son las diarias se da cuenta de que hubo
vulneraciones a los derechos
fundamentales así como también un uso
desmedido de la fuerza de parte de los
agentes policiales otro de los aspectos
importantes de este concluyente informe
es que de parte del ejecutivo
hubo una mirada que puso en duda
justamente la legitimidad de las
manifestaciones al criminalizar las
específicamente hay que recordar que uno
de los momentos más complejos de todo
este proceso fue cuando el presidente
viniera señaló que se estaba en guerra
encontró un enemigo poderoso haciendo
alusión justamente a quienes estaban en
las calles protestando por distintas
causas sociales dentro de estas
conclusiones de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos se
pone en especial énfasis en la
reparación en particular para las
personas que sufrieron traumas oculares
o daños permanentes productos de los
agentes represivos en este caso la
policía
hay un elemento adicional se hace un
foco en particular respecto de la escasa
preparación del cuerpo policial de
carabineros en chile- que debido a la
alta demanda que se debieron ha obligado
justamente a enfrentar producto de
múltiples manifestaciones no dieron
abasto cometiendo excesos que en algunos
casos parecían ser sistemáticos de allí
importancia que la convención
interamericana de derechos humanos pone
uno de los énfasis particulares la
reparación específica para todos quienes
fueron vulnerados durante este periodo
en reinounido de la policía
metropolitana de londres informó que
investigará las fiestas realizadas en la
residencia oficial del primer ministro
boris johnson durante los últimos dos
años por considerar que hubo una
potencial violación de las regulaciones
por ccoo y 19 el anuncio de la nueva
pesquisa llega a pocas horas de que se
conozcan los resultados de otra
investigación interna pero al menos tres
celebraciones
soy walk doy la bienvenida a la decisión
de la policía de realizar su propia
investigación porque creo que ayudará a
dar al público la claridad que necesita
y ayudará a resolver los hechos más
aragón pero quiero asegurarle al
parlamento y al país que todo el
gobierno y yo estamos enfocados al 100%
tratando las prioridades de las personas
incluso en el papel del liderazgo del
reino unido para proteger la liberalidad
alrededor del mundo y los más de mil
manifestantes salieron a las calles de
uagadugú y otras ciudades de burkina
faso para mostrar su apoyo a los
militares que derrocaron al presidente
rock kaboré quien renunció después de
ser capturado la comunidad económica de
estados de áfrica occidental denunció
que la dimisión fue forzada
tras el golpe militar estos
manifestantes celebran el derrocamiento
del presidente rock kaboré sostienen una
foto del teniente coronel pone rey
xandao gotham y bajo el nombre fuerte
del país entre las banderas de burkina
faso se destacan algunas de rusia dentro
de la multitud como en mali algunos
burkineses quieren que moscú coopere con
su país para luchar contra la amenaza
yihadista
el pueblo burkinés pide el apoyo de
rusia en esta lucha encarnizada
si rusia puede iniciar nuestra lucha
bienvenido sea
los burkineses esperan que la situación
de seguridad mejore rápidamente con el
nuevo poder militar desde hace dos años
el presidente rocks kaboré era cada vez
más cuestionado por su incapacidad de
acabar con los repetidos ataques que se
acudían al país largo bono mack creo que
ha llegado el momento oportuno porque
hemos advertido al gobierno de su mala
gestión en materia de seguridad con
jugadas de samal gobernanza material y
crisis entonces arias vamos a ver si
preocupa
son hombres sabios los que han tomado el
poder y con la ayuda de la sociedad
civil creo que venceremos a la hidra
terrorista
de género terrorista
por su parte ni el antiguo partido
gobernante ni la oposición han
reaccionado desde que los militares se
tomaron el poder la junta anunció el
martes la reapertura de las fronteras
aéreas las fronteras terrestres ya están
abiertas a los vehículos que transportan
ayuda humanitaria o equipos para las
fuerzas de seguridad pero a pesar de
dichas medidas la situación en burkina
faso no deja de ser alarmante para la
comunidad económica de estados de áfrica
occidental el bloque condenó la toma del
poder por parte de los militares y
aseguró que el presidente renunció al
ser amenazado e intimidado por los
militares convocando a una reunión de
emergencia y un rechazo que comparte
francia advirtiendo que seguirá el
panorama del país minuto a minuto se
espera que el presidente francés
emmanuel marco también se reúna con los
líderes de la región
llegamos hacia el final de esta misión
los invitamos a ampliar todas las
noticias y repetir este y otros
programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom feliz noche para todos
[Música]